new Bordeaux a modern city with
traditional southern values
underestimated how fires gonna go what
he was willing to do visit the historic
French Ward and enjoy local cuisine at
one of our five-star restaurant killing
them wasn't enough
Lincoln Clay was using them to send a
message or spend the afternoon and who
are you and take in its natural splendor
Salle marcano had no idea what he was
going to unleash new Bordeaux safety
family are headed for me make it your
next vacation destination this city
survived war of 1812 the Civil War and
God knows how many hurricanes but when
Lincoln clay went after the mob he
inflicted more damage than all the wars
and hurricanes combined
hey everyone I'm Hayden Blackman
creative director and studio head at
hangar 13 what you've just seen is our
introduction to mafia 3 an open-world
crime drama set in new Bordeaux our
version of New Orleans in 1968 one of
the most tumultuous years in American
history in mafia 3 you'll play as
Lincoln clay an orphan and Vietnam vet
who falls in with new Bordeaux's black
mom when the black mob is betrayed and
slaughtered by the Italian mob led by a
guy named Sal Martino Lincoln becomes
fixated on revenge
as Lincoln you'll wage a brutal war
against the Italians disrupting the
balance of power in new Bordeaux's
underworld and ultimately creating a new
crime family out of the ashes of the old
by recruiting three under bosses all
with personal vendettas against Salman
Khan oh history tells me they're giving
you more guns might be unhealthy me it's
not like that not anymore
I'll see to it they get in the hands of
the right people you're much too serious
about all this it takes the fun out of
it AIDS was no worse than good hopin you
could get us all killed
hey that I could I'll clean this mess up
the reason for you to stick around
remember our deal I'm expecting to cut
of everything you bring it hey I know
how this [ __ ] works you'll get your
money
there's Cassandra the leader the Haitian
gang we've been trying to get a foothold
in the city for months Burke who was
once loyal Desalle marcado but now wants
to see him destroyed for his own
personal reasons and Vito Scaletta who
has been sidelined by the Marco knows
and wants his piece of the action
today we're going to jump straight into
the middle of Lincoln's war with the mob
and his attempts to build and maintain
his new criminal family we're going to
start in the bayou and head for the
Frenchwoman
in mafia 3 we treat new Bordeaux as a
main character we've not only worked
hard to capture a unique time in place
but also to ensure that everything the
player does in the open world propels
Lincoln forward in the narrative we've
also given the city its own diverse
criminal ecologies which play a huge
role in Lincoln's quest to tear down the
mall
let's take a look at just a few of the
very districts in new Bordeaux and what
lurks beneath the surface and in the
back alleys of the city
our reimagined version of New Orleans is
made up of ten districts each with its
own distinct flavor we have the scenic
and mysterious by you which is ripe for
exploration
but is also where the Italian mob and
their allies run guns and produce
moonshine
to the west of the city is vibrant
delray Hall which is home to Lincoln in
a surrogate family before they are
betrayed by the Italian mob
eventually the hollow is taken over by
the Dixie mob who kick up to the
Italians and use the neighborhood as the
base of operations for heroin and sex
reigns
to the north of the city is majestic
Frisco fields with its manicured lawns
and mansions this is also where the
marcano family has partnered with the
racist Southern Union and cooks PCP at
the local University
and of course in the center of the city
is the historic French war a constant
party run by Sal Marco knows brother
known around town as uncle Lou but it's
Lou who deals smack and provides
high-class call girls to wealthy VIPs
throughout the iconic district
uncle Lou's operation is Lincoln's focus
right now as capturing the French word
for his own under bosses will strike a
major blow against the Italian mob we
can hurt Lou in many different ways but
here we've decided to go after want to
lose pimps Oscar sabato who provides Lou
with thousands in cash every week before
we go after Oscar and his crew we want
to resupply we can do this by calling in
our weapons dealer an associate who has
been introduced to us by Cassandra once
the mobile store arrives we can pick out
the gear that will best suit our
playstyle as with most of the encounters
in mafia 3 Oscar and his crew can be
taken on in many different ways we can
go in guns blazing we can take a
stealthy approach we can even call in
reinforcements it's really all up to the
player but in this playthrough we've
decided to use my favorite approach
which is going in a little quiet to kill
Oscar and then fighting our way out
you know
all right so we've killed Oscar sabato
which is a major blow to lose cashflow
and will eventually put him into hot
water with his brother Sal but now we
need to get the hell out of here see
that [ __ ]
yeah I'm recharged
Oh
here you can see that one of Oscars guys
has made it to a phone and called in
reinforcements
fortunately the player can call in a
favor of his own from Vito muscle to
bust some heads I need you to reward
now we've killed Oscar sabato we've cut
Luzerne by more than $10,000 bringing us
one step closer to we want to keep
hitting him where it hurts but there are
many different ways that we can do this
we can destroy uncle Lou's drug boats we
can interrogate his pimps and dealers we
can rob as bagman we can even take over
his drug den and brothel killing Oscar
sabato is only one of many ways to cut
into Lou's action
customers coming in
once Lincoln throttles lose ability to
kick up the South blue trips up in order
to get back into Sal's good graces Lew
arranges a fundraiser for a crooked
politician aboard one of his river boats
Lincoln learns about this and sees an
opportunity to kill them one of Sal's
most valuable Capo's
we hit something
none for you worry about let's get you
upstairs your fan out watch the rest of
the boat this sure [ __ ] wasn't an
accident
you
if I could get your attention please
stop this goddamn boat
get your attention there was a collision
we don't know the extent of the damage
to the ship but what are you going to
let us off they stopped their boat but
my crew is looking into it if you can
stay right here the casino
thank you
the crew will provide instructions on
how to make a gnarly
yeah
oh yeah
Oh
don't go away
[ __ ] away
that's far enough you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you take another Skippy Kitsch
you think I give a [ __ ] about some
politicians place ah I don't even know
what's going on
you
dear sir
are you
let's talk to through just two of us
hello Lord listen I got money you have
it all just don't kill me I don't want
money
how will you send a message to your
brother yeah anything odd you see you
see Lord oh my
blew dead the French word is ours and
every time we take over a district in
the game Lincoln calls a sit-down to
hand that district over to one of his
under bosses to run the day-to-day and
this sit-down we know that there's going
to be a bit of drama because in this
particular playthrough Lincoln has given
a lot of territory Cassandra while
practically ignoring birth your and I
are on the line here Lincoln named
expecting good things I don't give a
flying [ __ ] who has what Rockets this
earth it's mine god damn it and I want
to stop that anything else
and ask you to be patient Burke and give
everyone a chance to weigh in on this I
got no idea which way you leaning on
this and I get a you two got history to
call back on at least one that didn't
involve him trying to kill Sammy but
next time I prefer you cool out with the
games and just make the call
sorry Burke's all riled up I know that's
a [ __ ] pain in the ass but splitting
this district up like you did just makes
things worse you got to make a hard call
you and I hope it goes my way do right
by me or they'll be hell to pay a chalky
trust ain't something that comes easy to
be kiddin but I wish it did you get is
to me my con is gonna [ __ ] yourself we
talk about making money order comes down
to is respect I hope we can get things
back on track birth but we're not gonna
do it with this part of the city Vito's
gonna call the shots there one Asad
miserable fool I am preferable even in
you but there will be no more of may
foolishness the next day they see your
black hide it will be the end of a guard
I'm gone you and Burke have history
people between you but you gotta forget
all that and deal with this quickly the
mick is gonna be a problem until he
ain't
understand if Bergkamp fall in line ride
things out when they don't go his way
and he's not the partner we need I'll
deal with him well you're about to see
what happened for every player but
because of the choices we've made in
this playthrough Burke has decided to
betray link forcing Lincoln to confront
him on his home turf
Oh
so there's your look at mafia 3 coming
out on October 7th for PlayStation 4
Xbox one and PC